that new covet variant is spreading fast
in britain ambulances are
lining up outside hospitals to drop off
patients and most of the country is now
under the strongest coronavirus
restrictions
charlie dagetta is in london charlie
good morning
good morning to you yes another 20
million people are waking up here today
in the highest
lockdown tier in england here at the
river thames new year's eve would
normally be filled with
fireworks and celebrations but not
tonight
the nearly nationwide lockdown extension
was expected if dreaded nonetheless
kovid loves the crowd so please leave
the parties for later in the year
here's why the more contagious variant
of the coronavirus is on the rampage
spreading far faster than at any time
during the pandemic
daily infections have risen to more than
50 thousand
hospitals are already buckling under the
highest rate of covet patients
ever seen the stay at home order now
impacts three quarters of england
all non-essential shops businesses gyms
pubs
restaurants shut other european
countries are taking drastic measures
to contain rising infection rates too
france will deploy a hundred thousand
police to stop big crowds from gathering
for new year's eve celebrations
germany intends to extend its lockdown
as that country records more than a
thousand deaths in one day for the first
time
hardest hit britain may be offered a
lifeline as the oxford astrazeneca
vaccine
begins rollout next week the focus
really now is on saving lives
and enabling the healthcare system to
get back to something approaching normal
it will increasingly become a race
between the vaccine
and the virus but not only did kovit
have a head start
it's picking up speed
health secretary matt hancock described
it as a day of mixed emotions great news
about the vaccine
terrible news about this lockdown all
topped off
with britain leaving the eu isolated
and uncertain david charlie thank you